die Feuerwehrleute von Berlin das ist
eine Truppe die einen der härtesten Jobs
macht den es hier in Deutschland so gibt
sie erinnern sich gerade erst im so
komplizierten Einsatz bei diesem
Großbrand den Munitionslager in Berliner
Grunewald da waren die Feuerwehrleute
bei dieser irrenhitze wirklich bis zur
absoluten Erschöpfung im Einsatz jetzt
der Hammer die Politik hier in Berlin
sie kürzt genau diesen feuerwehrhelden
mit diesem schrieb hier das Trinkwasser
unglaubliches Story normalerweise kriegt
jede Wache reichlich Mineralwasser zum
Durst löschen in diesem
schweißtreibenden einsetzen aber dieses
Trinkwasser das wird jetzt rationiert
kein Geld mehr da die Berliner
feuerwehrhelden den Berlin jetzt nicht
mal mehr Wasser bezahlen will unser
Kolonist Gunnar shoppelius bei uns
unglaubliche Geschichte typisch Berlin
typisch Berlin denn es wird gespart
genau da wo man nicht sparen darf beim
Personal und vor allen Dingen beim
Sicherheitspersonal
das Wasser wird geplant für ein Jahr
Wasser brauchst du in der im Büro so wie
wir auch als Feuerwehrmann du brauchst
es aber vor allem auch vor Ort wir
hatten in diesem Jahr sehr viele
Großbrände Lagerhallen haben gebrannt es
war sehr heiß und also wurde mehr Wasser
verbraucht und weil man so knapp geplant
hatte ist das Geld jetzt alle und wie es
in einer Behörde so ist dauert es dann
ein paar Wochen bis das Geld wieder
freigegeben ist und in diesen Wochen
haben sie kein Mineralwasser auf den
und man glaubt es nicht ich glaube es
gibt Zuschauer in diesem Land die es gar
nicht glauben werden und ich möchte es
eigentlich nur ungern erzählen dass in
Berlin so zugeht fehlt nur noch dass sie
zum Löschen ihr eigenes Wasser
mitbringen müssen ganz so weit ist es
auch in Berlin noch nicht aber
tatsächlich das Trinkwasser das
Mineralwasser wird diesen die jeden Tag
wirklich in harten Job machen den wird
das rationiert was sagt das auch über
Respekt aus sehr sehr wenig und wir
haben im Umgang mit den
Sicherheitskräften hier ein großes
respektproblem von Seiten der Politik
das fängt schon mit der Ausrüstung an
die Feuerwehr hat zu wenig Fahrzeuge die
Feuerwehr hat eine mangelhafte
Ausrüstung immer noch trotz aller
Besserungen und die Feuerwehr hat zu
wenig Personal die Feuerwehr macht
Überstunden und wir haben mehrfach
berichtet dass Einsätze nicht mehr voll
bestückt werden können hier in der
Hauptstadt Deutschlands fahren Leute zu
einer Unfallstelle um Erste Hilfe zu
leisten die eigentlich einen Brand
löschen müssen es geht drunter und
drüber und letztendlich versteht es
keiner so richtig warum die Politik sich
nicht mit aller Kraft und zwar mit
Leidenschaft hinter diese Leute stellt
von denen so viel abhängt dann gundern
noch mal ganz schnell da ist seine
Kamera direkt in die Kamera an die
Regierende Bürgermeisterin von Berlin an
die innensenatorin in diesem Jahr muss
man ja fast sagen wasserskandal bei der
deutschen Feuerwehr deine Botschaft an
die die Botschaft an unsere Regierende
Bürgermeisterin also hier von Berlin aus
wäre dort sparen wo man sparen kann und
nicht dort sparen wo man nicht sparen
darf und das ist zuallererst das
Personal im öffentlichen Dienst und sie
sind die Dienstherren Frau Regierende
Bürgermeisterin also bitte Wasser in die
Wachen ja wassermarsch in diesem Fall
danke an Gunnar shoppelius hier bei Bild
live danke dir für die klare Meinung
[Musik]